thank you
that's me or just glad I'm not snow
white
I thought we'd bring her out and do the
Lambada the forbidden dance
she was a little finicky you know these
animated characters you give him a hand
they want a thumb you know it's one of
those things but ladies and gentlemen
wasn't that piece of film remarkable
Chuck working his film
there are 330 feature films in that
five-minute montage and what's amazing
is according to Paramount not one is yet
to go into profit
but we're here tonight to celebrate the
greatest year in the history of motion
pictures this is our greatest year ever
you know the box office this year
worldwide was over five billion dollars
thank you
five billion a roughly half of what Jack
Nicholson made on Batman this is a rich
man he just bought land in Japan now I'm
telling you jack is so rich Morgan
Freeman drove them here tonight I'll
tell you that right now
whoa I got it you want one more I got
one more you got it
Jack is so rich John Peter still cuts
his hair
to get him from
basketball hi I feel better
mr. Maldon was right and while I was
speaking I found his wallet in the
dressing room I don't know why he's
leaping cash around but ladies and
gentlemen he was talking about the
amazing things that are happening in the
world today and I think about it six
months ago who would have possibly
thought the Berlin wall would come down
that Nelson Mandela would be freed
and most incredibly meryl streep would
not be nominated for an Academy Award
but a lot of great people were in a very
eclectic group that we have tonight
beginning with the lovely Miss Jessica
Tandy
she of course is nominated for Driving
Miss Daisy the movie that apparently
directed itself and
and what's amazing is at 80 years of age
tonight would become the second oldest
Oscar recipient ever the first is
Shirley MacLaine was 915 I believe
but on the other end of the age spectrum
is the great filmmaker mr. Spike Lee
whose
whose breakthrough film do the right
thing is nominated for Best Original
Screenplay tonight
based on an idea of art buckwalds but
you know I'm kidding I'm just kidding
I'm kidding
was Andy Rooney but you know ladies and
gentlemen
and nominated again tonight is alleging
himself Marlon Brando mr. Brando is and
who can forget who can forget the last
time that mr. Brando one which is for
the Godfather which you know was now 18
moons ago some aluminum but tonight
the band loved it look at him we are
being seen by over billion people around
the world which is only right because
our industry is now international I mean
sooner or later everybody does business
with everybody Hyman Roth but ladies and
gentlemen later tonight we're going to
be going live to Russia with today
Disney announced plans to do the life
story of Mikhail Gorbachev it's gonna be
called Honey I Shrunk the party
these are good and right here in town
Hollywood has definitely taken on a
foreign flavor an Australian owes 20th
Century Fox MGM is being bought by an
Italian whose promise only one small
change from now on the line is not gonna
roar he's gonna be taking the fifth
and of course Columbia Pictures all
right I'll bring out Jack Valenti now
okay
Columbia Pictures gonna be owned is
owned by the great Japanese Sony
Corporation which makes it a little
different to do business over there
it's that Japanese film feeling when you
walk into the building everybody's out
of sync well he'll be seeing you soon
why don't you have a seat he's talking
on the car phone now he'll be coming in
later uh would you like it's very
different
but
and pitching ideas to movies there is
very different it's very different I was
sitting there the other day with some of
the new Sony Columbia executives and I'm
telling about this movie that I had an
idea for and it's a love story I'm
telling them I'm saying it's very
romantic
it starts in Central Park and the
couples in a rowboat right in the middle
of the lake and then Godzilla come up
beneath them know quite what I had in
mind but it's an amazing show that we
have tonight were going all around the
world I know what you're thinking as you
look at me where's my opening production
I know you miss it don't you
where's that big terrible number that
usually opens the Oz where is that
number where they take all the nominees
for Best Picture put them into one
medley well you won't be seeing that
tonight you won't see that number that
usually you won't see that number that
usually begins it's a wonderful night
for us
Oscar Oscar who will win the nominees
the Best Picture are me and my left foot
happened down that field of tree
cuckoo place where ghosts and flares
is this heaven no Jackson it's highway
when you see shoeless joe swinging right
now in the lockout Fay Vincent
arbitration on a night but all me
happening
we belong two of you to quote Dead Poets
Society what Whitman I mean he it's
great in a segregated stain Driving Miss
Daisy back home nature this view to get
me to shoe he's driving me crazy
I'm Driving Miss Daisy back July
buh-bye
if you finish it they will applaud
okay do some makeup man get ready we've
got an early call